this country of the United States was
not built by those who waited and rested
and wish to look behind them and not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
all we have built all we have worked for
would be destroyed in the first 24 hours
there are some who say that communism is
the wave of the future let them come to
Berlin he was an American politician who
served at the 35th President of the
United States of America he was
assassinated in Dallas Texas on November
22nd 1963 he continues to rank highly in
polls of the general public and
historians as one of the greatest
presidents of all time he's John F
Kennedy and here is my take on his top
ten rules for success rule number two is
my personal favorite and I'm curious to
figure out which one you guys like the
best and as always as he's talking and
he says something really meaningful then
that resonates with you please leave it
in the comments below and put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
surely the opening vistas of space
promise high cost and hardships as well
as high reward so it is not surprising
that some would have us stay where we
are a little longer to rest to wait
bought this city of Houston this state
of Texas this country of the United
States was not built by those who waited
and rested and wished to look behind
them
[Music]
this country was conquered by those who
move forward and so will space in the
long history of the world only a few
generations have been granted the role
of defending freedom in its hour of
maximum danger
I do not shrink from this responsibility
I welcome it
I do not believe that any of us would
exchange places with any other people or
any other generation the energy the
faith the devotion which we bring to
this endeavor will light our country and
all who serve it and the glow from that
fire can truly light the world and so my
fellow Americans ask not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country
my fellow citizens of the world ask not
what America will do for you but what
together we can do for the freedom of
man finally whether you are citizens of
America or citizens of the world ask of
us here the same high standards of
strength and sacrifice which we ask of
you with a good conscience are only sure
reward with history the final judge of
our deeds let us go forth to lead the
land we love asking his blessing and his
help but knowing that here on earth
God's work must truly be our own some
say that it is useless to speak of peace
or world law or world disarmament and
that it will be useless until the
leaders of the Soviet Union adopt a more
enlightened attitude I hope they do I
believe we can help them do it
but I also believe that we must
re-examine our own attitude as
individuals and as a nation for our
attitude is as essential as theirs and
every graduate of this school every
thoughtful citizen who despairs of war
and wishes to bring peace should begin
by looking inward by examining his own
attitude towards the possibilities of
peace towards the Soviet Union towards
the course of the Cold War and towards
freedom and peace here at home first
examine our attitude towards peace
itself too many of us think it is
impossible
too many think it is unreal but that is
a dangerous defeatist belief
it leads to the conclusion that war is
inevitable that mankind is doomed that
we are gripped by forces we cannot
control
we need not accept that view our
problems a man-made therefore they can
be solved by man
and man can be as big as he wants no
problem of human destiny is beyond human
beings man's reason and spirit have
often solved the seemingly unsolvable
and we believe they can do it again but
why some say the moon I choose this as
our goal and they may well ask why climb
the highest mountain five thirty five
years ago fly the Atlantic why does Rice
play Texas we choose to go to the moon
we choose to go to the moon
[Music]
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we are willing to
accept one we are unwilling to postpone
and one we intend to win and the others
too we observe today not a victory of
party but a celebration of freedom
symbolizing an end as well as a
beginning signifying renewal as well as
change for I have sworn before you and
Almighty God the same solemn oath our
forebears prescribed nearly a century
and three quarters ago the world is very
different now for man holds in his
mortal hands the power to abolish all
forms of human poverty and all forms of
human life and yet the same
revolutionary beliefs for which our
forebears fought are still at issue
around the globe the belief that the
rights of man come not from the
generosity of the state but from the
hand of God we do not forget today that
we are the heirs of that first
revolution let the word go forth from
this time and place to friend and foe
alike that the torch has been passed to
a new generation of Americans born in
this century tempered by war disciplined
by a hard and bitter
proud of our ancient heritage and
unwilling to witness or permit the slow
undoing all those human rights though
which this nation has always been
committed and to which we are committed
today at home and around the world
[Music]
let every nation know whether it wishes
us well or I'll that we shall pay any
price bear any burden meet any hardship
support any friend oppose any foe to
assure the survival and the success of
Liberty we are confronted primarily with
a moral issue it is as old as the
scriptures and is as clear as the
American Constitution the heart of the
question is whether all Americans are to
be afforded equal rights and equal
opportunities whether we are going to
treat our fellow Americans as we want to
be treated if an American because his
skin is dark cannot eat lunch in a
restaurant open to the public if he
cannot send his children to the best
public school available if he cannot
vote for the public officials who
represent him if in short he cannot
enjoy the full and free life which all
of us want then who among us would be
content to have the color of his skin
changed and stand in his place who among
us would then be content with the
counsels of patience and delay one
hundred years of delay of past whose
President Lincoln between the slaves yet
their heirs their grandsons are not
fully free they are not yet freed from
the bonds of injustice they not yet not
yet freed from social and economic
oppression and this nation for all its
hopes and all its boasts will not be
fully free until all its citizens are
free it is discouraging to read a recent
authoritative Soviet text on military
strategy and find on page after page
wholly baseless and incredible claims
such as the allegation that American
imperialist circles are preparing to
unleash different types of war that
there is a very
real threat of a preventative war being
unleashed by American imperialists
against the Soviet Union
and that the political aims and I quote
of the American imperialists are to
enslave economically and politically the
European and other capitalist countries
and to achieve world domination by means
of aggressive war unquote truly as it
was written long ago the wicked flee
when no man pursueth yet it is sad to
read these Soviet statements to realize
the extent of the gulf between us but it
is also a warning a warning to the
American people not to fall into the
same trap as the Soviets not to see only
a distorted and desperate view of the
other side not to see conflict as
inevitable accommodation as impossible
and communication as nothing more than
an exchange of threats no government or
social system is so evil that its people
must be considered as lacking in virtue
as Americans we find communism
profoundly repugnant as a negation of
personal freedom and dignity but we can
still hail the Russian people for their
many achievements in science and space
in economic and industrial growth in
culture in acts of courage among the
many traits the peoples of our two
countries have in common none is
stronger that our mutual abhorrence of
war almost unique among the major world
powers we have never been at war with
each other
and no nation in the history of battle
ever suffered more than the Soviet Union
in the Second World War at least twenty
million lost their lives countless
millions of homes and families were
burned or sacked a third of the nation's
territory including two-thirds of its
industrial base was turned into a
wasteland a loss equivalent to the
destruction of this country east of
cago today should total war ever break
out again no matter how our two
countries will be the primary target it
is an ironic but accurate fact that the
two strongest powers are the two in the
most danger of devastation all we have
built all we have worked for would be
destroyed in the first 24 hours and even
in the Cold War which brings burdens and
dangers to so many countries including
this nation's closest allies our two
countries they're the heaviest burdens
for we are both devoting massive sums of
money to weapons that could be better
devoted to combat ignorant poverty and
disease we are both caught up in a
vicious and dangerous cycle with
suspicion on one side breeding
suspicions on the other and new weapons
be getting counter weapons in short both
the United States and its allies and the
Soviet Union and its allies have a
mutually deep interest in a just and
genuine peace and in holding the arms
race agreements to this end are in the
interests of the Soviet Union as well as
ours and even the most hostile nations
can be relied upon to accept and keep
those treaty obligations and only those
treaty obligations which are in their
own interest so let us not be blind to
our differences but let us also direct
attention to our common interests and
the means by which those differences can
be resolved and if we cannot em now our
differences at least we can help make
the world safe for diversity where the
separation of church and state is
absolute
for no Catholic prelate to tell the
president should he be Catholic how to
act and no Protestant minister would
tell his parishioners for whom to vote
when no church or church school is
granted any public funds or political
preference and where no man is denied
public office merely because his
religion differs from the President or
might appoint him or the people who
might elect him I believe in an America
that is officially neither Catholic
Protestant no Jewish where no public
official either requests or accept
instructions on public policy from the
Pope the National Council of Churches or
any other ecclesiastical source where no
religious body seeks to impose its will
directly or indirectly upon the general
populace or the public acts of its
official and where religious liberty is
so individual but an act against one
church is treated as an act against all
a while this year it may be a Catholic
against whom the finger of suspicion is
pointed in other years it has been and
may someday be again a Jew or a Quaker
or Unitarian or a Baptist
it was Virginia's harassment of Baptist
preachers for example that led to
Jefferson's statue of religious freedom
today I may be the victim but tomorrow
it may be you to those nations who would
make themselves our adversary we offer
not a pledge but a request that both
sides begin anew the quest for peace
before the dark powers of destruction
unleashed by science engulf all humanity
in planned or accidental
self-destruction
we dare not tempt them with weakness for
only when our arms are sufficient beyond
doubt can we be certain beyond doubt
that they will never be employed but
neither can too great and powerful
groups of Nations take comfort from our
present course both sides overburdened
by the cost of modern weapons both
rightly alarmed by the steady spread of
the deadly atom yet both racing to order
that uncertain balance of terror that
stays the hand of mankind's final war so
let us begin anew remembering on both
sides that civility is not a sign of
weakness and sincerity is always subject
to proof let us never negotiate out of
fear but let us never fear to negotiate
[Music]
that both sides explore what problems
unite us instead of belaboring those
problems which divide us let both sides
for the first time formulate serious and
precise proposals for the inspection and
control of arms and bring the absolute
power to destroy other nations under the
absolute control of all nations
[Music]
let both sides seek to invoke the
wonders of science instead of its
terrorism together let us explore the
Stars conquer the deserts eradicate
disease tap the ocean depth and
encourage the arts and commerce let both
sides unite to heed in all corners of
the earth the command of Isaiah to undo
the heavy burdens and let the oppressed
go free and if a beachhead of
cooperation may push back the jungle of
suspicion let both sides join in
creating a new endeavor not a new
balance of power but a new world of law
where the strong adjust and the weak
secure and the peace preserve all this
will not be finished in the first 100
days nor will it be finished in the
first 1,000 days nor in the life of this
administration nor even perhaps in our
lifetime on this planet but let us begin
[Music]
in your hands my fellow citizens more
than mine will rest the final success of
Faria of our course there are many
people in the world who really don't
understand or say they don't what is the
great issue between the free world and
the Communist world let them come to
Berlin
[Applause]
there are some who say there are some
who say that communism is the wave of
the future let them come to Berlin and
there are some who say in Europe and
elsewhere we can work with the Communist
let them come to Berlin
and there are even a few who say that
it's true that communism is an evil
system but it permits us to make
economic progress Lots Enoch Berlin in
common
[Applause]
freedom has many difficulties and
democracy is not perfect but we have
never had to put a wall up to keep our
people in to prevent them from leaving
us all free men wherever they may live a
citizens of Berlin and therefore as a
free man I take pride in the words ich
bin ein bier Lena
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Natalie Moses
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did you learn in this video
from JFK what was the best rule for you
what are you going to apply to your
business or your life please leave in
the comments and I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Antonio from real men
real style Antonio thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book and sending
that tweet out it really really really
means a lot to me they each support me
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved I'll see you soon